uh it is still really unclear to me but
also to Nikki Haley why anyone should
vote for her according to Nikki Haley we
talked last week about how Nikki Haley
was asked like why would people vote for
you and it was basically like I don't
really know and identity politics well
I'm a different generation and you know
women power and I'm also a minority and
just very strange stuff to hear from
Republicans who claim to be against
identity politics she's now had another
week to try to come up with some policy
ideas she was asked about her record at
the U.N
she could name nothing other than that
she did a book
she didn't write a book she did a book
are these do these count as answers in
politics at this point or in Republican
politics we've been talking about
foreign policy this morning you did an
incredible job at the UN fighting for
America First how do you differentiate
yourself from the other candidates and
remember the other candidates Trump
right I mean that's it's Trump and Vivek
ramaswamy who who's whose announcement
went over like a lead balloon it's your
plan for foreign give us the plan
well you know one of the main things I
did at the United Nations that I think
is so important is I did a book that
focused on the 193 company countries the
193 companies in the oh my god let's
we've got to run that back the this this
is an answer she was asked what would
you do in terms of foreign policy
well you know one of the main things I
did at the United news that I think is
did a book that focused on the 193
company countries the percentage of time
they voted with us and how much foreign
aid we give them yeah uh Chef can you
tell us what would be your approach to
uh poultry based dishes if you were to
be hired to run this restaurant listen
one of the biggest things I did over the
last three months is I did a book where
I would list items available at
different restaurants
oh oh okay but so like what would what
would the poultry dishes be here it's
just completely incoherent and by the
way she did a book containing
information anyone can just Google about
different countries and by the way it's
not even clear she actually claims to
have written it notice that she said she
did a book rather than I wrote a book
this is really a problem in my eyes I
don't know the Republican voters care
about policy but she continues to do
this remember last week she was asked
you know what like why would anyone vote
for you and just very confusing answers
okay so I want to put up something from
the Wall Street Journal this week they
said you had a a great day your great
rollout day but they said you have to
provide a rationale for your candidacy
that you haven't done yet they said
you've got to answer this question about
why you versus anybody else in the in
the GOP field you know they're talking
about the fact that you say you know
America First America should be powerful
those are things that any GOP candidate
is going to say so why you
why not me you know I am a the wife of a
combat veteran I'm a mother of two
children one who's getting married and I
see how hard it is for her to look at
buying a home one that's in college and
I see what he's dealing with with woke
education you know I'm the daughter of
immigrant parents who are upset by
what's happening at the border I don't
want to wait for someone else to fix
this anyway so her as you might remember
her answer was basically
um you know there's there's people not
enjoying what they're being taught and
woke and you know I'm the daughter of
immigrants truly a horrendous candidate
I mean just horrifyingly bad and usually
candidates are able to cite reasons to
vote for them which we might say that's
not a good reason she's not even able to
cite what would count as a reason now if
we want to take a very quick look at the
latest polling
um you know it's not as bad as I thought
for Nikki Haley if we look at the most
recent a rated poll which is a Fox News
poll remember Fox News polling actually
isn't bad
it's conducted by Beacon research they
have a poll if it's Trump head to head
against Haley Trump crushes Haley 66-24
and that's not super shocking if it's a
multi-way poll it's Trump 43 followed by
DeSantis 28 and then Nikki Haley tied
for third with seven percent seven
percent's nothing to sneeze at given
that she just launched her campaign a
couple weeks ago
um it's it's not great and by the way if
I was a betting man I'm not my bet is
Nikki Haley does not end up getting
seven percent of the vote in the
Republican primary but it's not even
March of 2023 yet so so you know who
knows but uh listen I mean she's
starting with seven all right that's
something you can build from at least
hypothetically I don't know that you're
gonna build it by having no policy and
just saying you're younger than Trump a
woman and and of Indian Heritage I'm not
sure that that gets you beyond seven
percent but it will be interesting to
watch we'll take a very quick break I am
going to talk about the Scott Adams
racist meltdown uh I have a history with
Scott Adams we'll talk about that and
other things after this very short break